has your younger uncle
stop right there
[Laughter]
unless it says graduated from med school
early yeah it's trash
you got it uncle baby billy god damn
come here uncle baby he's 14 giving you
five bucks on your birthday
[Applause]
holy [ __ ] it's tough
all right
[Applause]
has your younger uncle ever tried to get
you to listen to his soundcloud
that's what younger uncles do
[Applause]
i'm telling you man it's to blow up it's
really going to blow up
now go to your room
how what's what's the age difference
[Music]
dude that's even weirder the closer it
gets how does that even happen you
should have said he was 12. my god
holy [ __ ]
and what's it as he's a rapper
that was the boyfriend right there
[Applause]
[ __ ] on her uncle's dreams right
there uncle baby don't have bars i'll
tell you that
that's fantastic i'm talking about the
straight truth right there what's his
rap name
rail just rail like r-a-i-l
oh of course
when you got a skylist in the family you
can't go changing
you don't really go up the middle with
punctuation
god damn what a beautiful question give
her a nice round that's a [ __ ]
home run home run
and make sure you check out rail on
soundcloud
[Applause]
this one where's eric l
there we go sounds like a nice gentleman
right there no he does not uh
i have some livestream cold artifacts
over here this guy's pretty trash aaron
what kind of work do you do man
okay all right vanna where'd you go to
school
very nice very nice
what was the uh was the gpa when he
graduated
whoa all right has a credit score
we might have some class in the building
and a burglary suspect for after the
show
yeah you're gonna get mugged in the
parking lot dude
like there's a [ __ ] now get him
out here with a credit card add this a
[ __ ]
all right
i put the i mean you come from garbage
i'm assuming yeah okay
is it garbage if your mom left your dad
to marry your pastor
there's a whole lot more
is it garbage if your mom left your dad
to marry your pastor and then your dad
married the pastor's ex-wife
there's more
[Applause]
and then the pastor's ex-wife groomed
your brother and now stepsister to
eventually marry each other
it's like a hillbilly yellowstone right
there
so everybody's now a hunky dory family
they all hate each other still i wonder
why what the [ __ ]
you don't know who's [ __ ] who jesus
christ
i'm pretty sure that last one was
illegal
get up there and marry your brother
sister let's go